ich will einmal ganz kurz dieses thema
aus der welt der diplomatie rausholen
aus der welt der anzüge und krawatten
die wir fast alle heute tragen und
reingehen zu den menschen die das alles
gerade aus baden und möglicherweise noch
noch viel mehr ausbaden müssen es gibt
ein ganz starkes bild von den
olympischen spielen in peking dass wir
uns einmal anschauen da haben sich zwei
sportler umarmt ein russischer und ein
ukrainischer sportler wintersportler
freestyler und danach gab es heftige
kritik auch von ihrer seite von der
ukrainischen seite das sei jetzt
wirklich nicht angezeigt da solle man
mehr professionalität mehr distanz
wahren lassen wenig was ist daran
schlimm wenn sich zwei menschen umarmen
ich glaube man muss das in einem
zusammenhang sehen und der zusammenhang
ist der dass wir gerade diese
schrecklichen bilder aus der ost ukraine
gesehen und klar ist dass russland für
diesen achtjährigen krieg verantwortung
geprägt dass zehntausende menschen opfer
geworden sind das zwei millionen ukraine
fliegen mussten aus dem don was das ist
die realität seit acht jahren und
angesichts dieser lage und angesichts
dessen dass diese bedrohung jetzt noch
viel schlimmer geworden ist und das wie
einen neuen riesigen krieg jetzt mitten
in europa befürchten müssen sind diese
bilder für für viele meiner landsleute
natürlich verstörende und deswegen bin
ich bei denen die sagen als sport muss
sein also wir sind froh dass ukrainische
athleten dass das unsere sportler auch
bei der olympia dabei waren aber wie
gesagt es geht darum dass das russland
von heute frei heutige russland
womöglich einen neuen einmal
plante und verwirklichen gang und
deswegen das sind zwei welten die
aufeinander prallen
reale lage in der wir heute leben müssen
der ukraine herr kornblum kann das
überhaupt falsch sein wenn sich zwei
sportler zwei männer zwei menschen
umarmt gleich welcher nationalität sie
gerade sind sie habe gerade ein sport
wettkampf gegeneinander geführt und
umarmen sich danach kann das falsch sein
nein natürlich nicht ich meine ich kenne
den fall nicht ich weiß auch nicht wie
die reaktion darauf war aber man muss
nicht vergessen man muss nicht vergessen
dass die nerven ja ziemlich blank sind
jetzt gerade in nuuk eine dass das dass
russland als land gar nicht teilnehmen
darf auf die olympiade war sein
verhalten auch wir wegen doping und so
schlecht war das russische sportler da
sozusagen als freiberufler teilgenommen
haben heute hätten wir das halt ich kann
die lage viele maschine erlebt ja wer
mehr wir wissen aus der vergangenheit
auch eigentlich sollte mich sehr genau
aus den zeiten der kelten des kalten
krieges das sport sehr oft in die
politik gezogen wird das ist vielleicht
zum traurig habe es ist so so ich hätte
nichts dagegen wenn eine ukrainische
russische spontis sich um haben das für
dich auch den geist der olympischen
spiele aber ich verstehe jetzt auch wenn
das vielleicht auch vor allem auf und
keine emotionen gibt paul ronzheimer
wenn wir über die menschen sprechen auf
den beiden seiten und jetzt gerade
anhand dieses so beeindruckenden fotos
dieser beeindruckende geschichte aus
peking
lassen sich die menschen auf beiden
seiten oder würde man sich sofort in die
arme fallen wenn die truppen dort
abziehen würden
nein die menschen hassen sich nicht ich
sehe dass insbesondere an vitali
klitschko die ich viel begleitet habe
der hat einen hintergrund in russland
und der ukraine und so geht es vielen
menschen hier und auch wenn wir an der
front unterwegs sind dann höre ich von
leuten die beschossen werden von der
separatisten seite oder von der
russischen seite von der russischen
armee seite das sie dann in donetsk also
bei den separatisten anrufen weil sie da
freunde haben also gerade hier wo ich
gerade stehe sind die familien getrennt
worden durch diese front und ich glaube
wir brauchen mehr bilder von ukrainern
und russen die sich umarmen was wir auch
brauchen und das verstört mich ist das
die menschen aufstehen gegen die politik
putins denn man muss einen unterschied
machen zwischen den menschen und der
politik und wir haben gesehen dass es
weder in europa noch in den usa oder in
russland demonstrationen gibt für den
frieden diese demonstration da 2003
gegen den irak krieg gegeben da waren
millionen auf der straße und jetzt und
das frustriert hier viele ukraine sehen
wir kaum unterstellt warum ist das so
herr stegner warum ist das so warum gab
es nicht am wochenende wir haben hier
immer den demo samstag in berlin da
kommen alle möglichen kleinen gruppen
zusammen warum haben wir nicht nur
massive große demonstration vor der
russischen botschaft
ich glaube dass die menschen frieden
wollen und dass sie deswegen die
unterstützt die das unterstützen was
momentan stattfindet nämlich das mit
allen diplomatischen wegen versucht wird
zu
dafür zu sorgen dass beim frieden bleibt
und sollte sich das ändern können sie
ganz sicher sein dass ganz viele
menschen auf dem straßen wären aber doch
diplomatie zu demonstrieren da er so was
könnte daher gibt die diplomatie
wirtschaft von den fahrten gemacht
verhandeln und übrigens gute
außenpolitik ist sowohl werte geleitet
als auch realitätsbezogen das muss ich
muss man dann auch mal dazu bei all dem
hinzufügen und deswegen weil die frage
ja vorhin war bin damals sagt wer da
sehr viel fern ist man kann einkassieren
für die position die man hat weil die
beiden nicht kenne kann ich ja vorher
nicht gesagt eine dumme frage mit der
nato und ich hab nur eine frage die
nicht auf der tagesordnung steht krieg
zu führen wäre das dümmste was man tun
könne und einen krieg hat nur verlierer
insbesondere die zivilbevölkerung und
deswegen müssen all die fragen gelöst
wenn er helfen auch nicht vergleichen
mit chamberlain und der zeit von hitler
wir haben jetzt andere verhältnisse und
wir müssen zu recht kommt übrigens mit
ländern die unsere werte nicht teilen
das gilt ja nicht nur vor was anderswo
die olympiade kabel stattfinden auch bei
taiwan oder hongkong gibt es durchaus
deutliche worte aber kein mensch schickt
dort waffen hin um zu warten ob die
satzung wird besser verschlossen
trotzdem noch meinen areal mit den roma
team zum erfolg zu kommen das
unterstützen die menschen auch alle
umfragen zeigen ich habe mir noch in
deutschland bei dem was sie sagen die
fachleute die regeln das schon grad weil
meine eindruck entstanden bisschen dass
wenn es jetzt demonstrationen gebe dass
aus ihrer sicht das nochmal öl ins feuer
gießen würde das wäre eine massive
solidaritätsbekundung für herrn melnik
nein das würde nicht überall die
menschen das würde nicht nur den scheuer
gießen sondern ganz im gegenteil alle
umfragen sagen uns dass die menschen
angst haben vor krieg dass sie das nicht
wollen dass sie uns vielleicht auch
deswegen dagegen sind und dass mit
waffen noch zu verstärken weil das
konflikt dem nicht militärisch gelöst
werden kann sondern musste damals haben
wir hoffen konnten eher unterschiedliche
meinung und die haben ja auch bei
anderen dingen und bei der konsum das
gesamt will ich ihm sagen ja natürlich
können wir über die gaspipeline streiten
und sie wäre auf dem tisch
logischerweise wenn der fall käme
umgekehrt sind natürlich auch die
amerikaner zweitgrößte öl
ist öllieferant nach kanada ist russland
an amerika also auch da ganz pragmatisch
runde wo man unterschiedlicher meinung
sein kann wir wollen uns dass sich
gegenseitig um die ohren hauen sondern
einfach nur sagen ich glaube es muss
eine diplomatische lösung des konflikts
geben eine andere kann es nicht gehen
hätte nur auf